okay guys it's Battaglia Reagan I am a
star talk all-star host and we are
actually replying this is type of itself
beside this excel of NYU
he is a molecular anthropologist and
biological anthropologist and I'm myself
anthropologist and we went to respond to
Tim Allen's tweet basically if there are
are Apes or we came from a wire there
still eight well it's a good question
it's been asked many many times talk if
at all the time as a professor and we
wanted to address that question because
again there are a lot of people that ask
especially those that question evolution
well the short answer is we did not
evolve from apes we have a common
ancestor with eight and and todd has a
really great analogy that I wanted to
share so the analogy that I like to use
is we obviously are descended from our
grandparents and so if we're descended
from her grandparents why are there
still cousins yeah why are the presents
still around I mean and someone could
say if dogs evolved from wolves fire
their soul wolf
they didn't evolve from them they have a
common ancestor and so instance Apes
and well actually one thing we should
clarify a tomb is actually our apes we
belong to the family home in a day which
includes all the greats I always joke
that some of us are greater than others
but the gradient grades include
chimpanzees bonobos gorillas orangutans
and humans but our closest genetic
relatives are bonobos and chimpanzees
and we diverged us you know from a
common ancestor that we share with with
chimp and vanilla and then chance if and
almost I've reached about give or take
so that's basically how that happened
and the thing is they're still evolving
right dr. Todd yeah they are literally
just as evolved as we are you have a
common ancestor and for the last six
million years they've been going on
their own way we can go on our own way
so anything living on a planet today is
equally evolved even bacteria yeah that
Pete would max go your own way you're
just going to keep going around why
right dr. Claude yeah yes yes
so yeah I hope that helps clarify and if
anybody asks you that in the future just
remember it's a common ancestor and
that's evolution is necessarily goal
driven you know a lot of people say well
why aren't monkeys you know one day
become humans well they don't have to
they're doing they're doing ok monkeys
right get along just fine then we have
any questions anybody want to go that
right there's a Diet Mountain Dew
they're cooler with the grapes here in
this lab by the way we're in the NYU
molecular pathology lab that dr. todd
runs one of you have this lab 20
soldiers yes probably longer than many
of you have been alive not me but me mu
so I know why aren't there dinosaurs if
we have Birds great question this is a
very good it is a good question well I
mean 65 million years ago an asteroid
hit off because you can't insula
modern-day Mexico and that decimated
many of well all the dinosaurs and a lot
of what survived were the smallest of
the small some of them being small
mammals which gave rise to bigger
mammals after that big Mesozoic
extinction of the dinosaurs that this
survived were the small warm-blooded
birds which weren't able to better
forage and survive and what would have
been basically in winter environment
with a lot of the vegetation the sea
flowers insects everything wiped out or
at least dramatically reduced and so a
small warm-blooded animal like a bird or
a small mammal was able to survive and
this is something that actually you
talked about before we add with a
question about like what could there be
Planet of the Apes it's a great question
so when the obviously have many movies
about that dr. cloud might have the same
theory that it would probably be planted
upon the cat and the reason based think
they are able to survive in about any
environment out there so that's really
key survival is not necessarily being
feeding and strong it's about being able
to adapt and survive
they're awesome attacks which are
monkeys by the way I'm actually often
referred to as a we speak speakers they
can live in and try and
marginal environments alongside you just
about anyone there next to humans they
are the most widely ranging primates
well yeah eventually they say they
published in the Japanese snow macaque
smart enough to use hot tub yeah and you
know wouldn't you thought those are too
much yes absolutely so I always joke
it's going to be the cat attack what's
the closest link to our eight ancestry
are we talking seven my own videos so
about six million years ago maybe just a
little before that we shared a common
ancestor with the chimpanzee so it was a
chimp
it was the common ancestor of humans and
just like your grandparents is the
common ancestor of you and your cousins
and so when that species split into two
it went basically extinct but it had
descendants one of which ultimately gave
rise to the two species of chimps and
one gave rise to all of the hominins all
of the australopithecines from early
Homo neanderthalensis anding from that
particular branch of the family tree
kind of like your paternal ancestry
versus your maternal ancestor they're
separate but you are comprised of both
of them yeah and it's I mean that this
ends just to explain that this study of
this common ancestry is called
paleoanthropology looking at our human
origins scanning some of them led to
different branches but some of them were
dead ends one of my favorite Hellman
species is Francis's Boise eye which is
this really cool looking really need
look installed
single flaring cheekbones big you know
crest on top of his head
huge molars but a dead end this meant
not crashing for a good reason
I wish I had a skull right now so I
actually have a Boise I necklace rocks
inside my swag SS but with all the
advances and
medical fields has has that caused
humans to stop evolving or does that
simply slow the process since it's
easier to survive solely a question and
that was right that's from not giving
people shout out like I should I'm sorry
that's from Christine Marie Hernandez
frisky I hope I'm saying your name right
so this is a question I get all the time
I actually teach courses on health and
human evolution and we are fertility
balding one of the most basic
definitions of evolution is actually a
change in allele frequency over time so
every time new immigrants enter some
place any time basically a baby is born
you have a new combination of wheels and
frequency of those alleles so you are
having evolution um while a lot of
people think we stop the moment because
we save people's lives wouldn't have
survived I mean if I was out on the
Savannah right now without these classes
I'd be Leopard father
yeah we're not yeah lion kibble Riley
that's a sort of a minor component we
are changing our gene frequencies in the
world frequencies the diseases that
spread around the world cause people who
are better able to survive certain kinds
of diseases to have more offspring than
others so another addition is a
continuous ongoing process we're playing
with it on the edges with some of our
biomedical advances but we're not
solving it really in fact we may be
accelerating with the things we're doing
to the environment the chemicals are
exposing ourselves we're creating a new
evolutionary environment that causes us
to have to respond we're a great
evolutionary force and even looking at
bacteria and antibiotics and how those
are quickly evolving up okay kit Adnan
Khan what's your ask can we predict
evolution how a species will evolve in
the future Oh another good part also I
can tell you absolutely we will go
accept all species are safe
99.9% of all species that have ever
lived are now extinct and so that and it
might not be in a bad way we might
actually shift and change and fall but a
million years from now you wouldn't
recognize people as we see them today so
we would still be their ancestors so
some of our genes will have survived but
the things we call Homo sapiens may have
shifted of change and we really take in
consideration is a lot of how we look
and how our culture involves is very
much determined by the environment and
the environments as we know is
dramatically change it's hard to say
what we're going to even how we're going
to survive or what we're going to look
like you know thousands of years into
the future it means that evolution is a
slow process that we are definitely like
dr. Todd better speeding it up Troy
Coleman has an excellent question there
is cannibalization the death of natural
selection actually could it um in fact
it's actually the cause of it so if you
think of the domestication of plants and
animals large numbers of people or some
living together that's good learning
tons to evolve new mechanisms that
digest dairy digests right lutein and
all of these things to actually get
along with large numbers to have
pathogens measles and mumps rubella and
smallpox spreading around we have to
evolve civilization it's like moving to
a jungle into the savanna moving from
one island to another it's actually
created a different teaming environment
the different landscapes that we need to
quickly adapt to and unfortunately
sometimes it doesn't always happen as
quickly as we want that's when you have
you know mass die-offs humans happen
Rachel Thompson asked why address these
kinds of comments at all and should more
public light on something so obviously
and valid hi get out
and creationist I asked that very
question but I think they do need good
responses if those have questions go
unanswered
people just assume oh yeah you answer
them therefore they must be right I mean
it's a it's a logical fault to make that
assumption but I think we need to push
back whenever possible and I hate the
onion it's the thing though you know it
will come about there is no such thing
as a dumb question I try to be as kind
as possible because I do get young folk
asking the same question as genell and
ass clearly if you really wanted to know
the answer you to google it there are
tons of great articles out there and one
literature to explain why there are
still eight if we quote and book all
from them because of the common answer
but at the same time I feel like if we
just dismiss them all together like
doctors Todd said what you're talking
about creationism is right evolution
doesn't exist and then we and we lose
people fight against if you know willful
ignorance and more than anything I think
we want to see a more science literate
world in the United States especially
since those voters out there with them
voting with their minds and their mind
assigns literate because a lot of
policies need to be informed by
peer-reviewed science including things
like evolution and understanding rules
evolution in how it works
any more questions
oh wait pots don't we have a little
friend there we just rented you just
wanted to do this this is our bathroom
solid Wednesday's I do for me okay
olives on today it is a monkey again
related to its sharing common ancestor
appears after Stan apps are there events
or things that can increase or decrease
evolution and it's possible does that
mean that eventually evolution will
reach a cap changing environments
clearly affect evolution Eva even long
periods of stasis so
basically evolution never stops again
every arrival and every generation every
new child born is a combination of new
genes inherited at random from the
parents so there were always putting new
combinations of genes that may or may
not survive either in a changing
environment or a stable environment so
just because of the way biology words
and the evolution is the most
fundamental fact the most fundamental
part of biology so it will never be
count yeah I mean down at the cellular
level is it it keeps on going at my
hostage that's the thing I think it's
hard is it happened so slowly that it's
hard to see times I thought it literally
is invisible to like the naked eye you
have this allele that will fight off
that disease you don't know about it
until you're exposed to that disease but
your grandchildren might survive because
you passed on a key gene in a disease
that you don't see for two more
generations but when it pops up BAM
you're very thankful you have it okay
Jason babe what's the closest link to
our eighth ancestry oh we do this one
before we can do it and we can do
another thing homeless party well I mean
it's not clear if they mean which is our
Alice's living relative or which fossil
species is closest to that common
ancestor and there's actually several
fossil species we actually have three
candidates for that closest link if you
will so he'll a perpetuity on when
chances are two Pittacus and Aurora and
two Connexus all with existing somewhere
between five and a half and six and a
half million years ago right near that
six millionaires slit between chimps all
three might be on our side of
right none of them might be some P
before it some might actually be chumps
yes you don't know for children Japan's
but just real quickly our closest
genetic relatives are living relatives
are chimpanzees bonobos that for us to
share 98.7 percent of our DNA so thanks
so much for watching you guys again this
was dr. Todd digital graciously letting
us use his wonderful lab go back to the
left and I'm Natalia Reagan a star talk
all-star and I love to answering these
questions and keep asking these
questions take areas and keep looking
thank you or wash your hands hey did you
like that cool video huh well how about
a bunch of cool videos all commercial
free plus exclusive original content
that you can't find anyplace else all on
Startalk all-access calm